we have been focusing on reading DNA for
the last 40 50 years we've entered an
era of reading and writing DNA you know
if you like in the last five seven years
and we're now transitioning into an era
that we call the social genome era where
many aspects of our life are going to be
influenced by our own genetic and also
other types of bio data whether it's
microbiome immune phenotypical data etc
so as this the these different data
affect different parts of our day-to-day
life not just wellness and health and
you know medicines but also nutrition
and exposure to different components and
the environment etc you know it's a very
different world and we will have some of
the same questions that we're having
today on the digital revolution if you
like or out of the divet revolution
we're gonna have the same in the bio
revolution so we are entering the era of
the social genome boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sock UN we are in the beautiful
Cambridge Massachusetts we're gonna be
talking about the era of the social
genome we have Rodrigo Martinez joining
us on the show hello hey Alan how are
you good thank you so much for coming on
it's actually round two from arc fusion
that everyone did about a year ago yeah
Rodrigo is the chief marketing and
design officer at Veritas genetics where
they do whole genome sequencing for
under $1,000 and he's been doing that
for three years prior to that he spent
six years as life sciences chief
strategist at IDEO and with Juan
Enriquez he co-founded Harvard Business
School's life sciences project and term
Bioeconomy so let's jump into this the
era of the social genome teaches about
what this is and why it's so important
yeah
look we're imagine we're in the early
90s
or even late 80s they're a bunch of
offices and government projects that
have really big computers and some of us
have our little you know Commodore 64
and you know you had your little Radio
Shack computer and some of those are in
the edge trying to figure out what to do
with these little things called
computers right and there's no way that
back then we can imagine things like
Facebook and Google and Amazon Prime and
election hacking and trolling and
bullying and all of the opportunities
and risks that we have today throughout
our life out of the digital revolution
right so that dimension you know think
about 20-30 years it's sort of where we
are in the bio world right we have been
focusing on reading DNA for the last 40
50 years we've entered an era of reading
and writing DNA you know if you like in
the last five seven years and we're now
transitioning into an era that we call
the social genome era where many aspects
of our life are going to be influenced
by our own genetic and also other types
of bio data whether it's microbiome
immune phenotypical data etc so as this
the these different data affect
different parts of our day-to-day life
not just wellness and health and you
know medicines but also nutrition and
exposure to different components in the
environment etc you know it's a very
different world and we will have some of
the same questions that we're having
today on the digital revolution if you
like or out of the divet revolution
we're gonna have the same in the bio
revolution so we are entering the era of
the social genome this is a really good
way of explaining it and you guys did
this in the blog article that you got
that you posted that we see with
computational capacity going from the
mainframes to the desktop computers in
our homes to the smartphones in our
pockets and that with the whole genome
it used to cost egregious billions of
dollars over
spans of over a decade to sequence a
whole genome now it's down to less than
a thousand dollars and the insights that
we can gain from the genome to live a
healthier and more fulfilling life and
there's so many of these insights so
this is kind of like you you're
explaining it's this revolutionary time
for biotechnology to come in and start
augmenting almost every single aspect of
our existence I want to hear from you
what exactly this is doing because
sometimes people don't necessarily know
how does this even happen do we take a
sample of my saliva and submit it into
Veritas genetics is this how we do yes
correct
so yeah we we have basically a service
both for consumers and for physicians
and clinics and also for researchers so
consumers go to our website and very
touched genetics calm and they order a
kit they have to read some important
documentation and get the proper you
know signatures they have to give their
consent etc because we're HIPAA
compliant right so there are series and
also gdpr compliant which is a standard
in Europe that we also support here for
all our customers and then we send a kid
to your home it's a very simple kid you
spin on a little tube send it back to us
and we sequence that DNA and our you
know top facilities that are have all
the acronyms that you can imagine CLIA
cap all of you know all of the acronyms
to to the highest standards
after we sequence we then interpret
those results and then you have a report
that you can look online it's a
web-based report you can also print it
but there's no point in printing it
really you want to you want to be able
to access it on your phone on your
computer and it basically details some
things that are in red meaning these
things are very important you need to
talk to your doctor about immediately
like you know these could have
significant life-threatening
consequences there's a section in yellow
like these are things risks that you
that you might may have given you
genetic map and things that you need to
you know you need to know about you need
to talk to your doctor about things that
you could adjust in your lifestyle to
reduce some of those risk etc and then
there's a whole series of things that we
think are are fine to know if you like
it's a bit more of infotainment you know
all the traits and some ancestry etc but
our focus is mostly on things that are
important for your health and that are
actionable and when we sit down together
in the future I want to really get into
the science of how to actually take a
saliva and turn that into over six
billion characters HTC's and G's correct
and then we can do that at a later time
but what I want to hear now is when I
get this digital report how do you know
what is critical read how do you know
what I need to act on right away is
specific locations in the sequence that
I have some sort of a mutation that I
need to go and take action on exactly so
we all have you know while we're more
than ninety nine point five or seven or
eight percent identical in our genomes
right and you right six point four
billion base pairs of letters we all
have different variants so somewhere
between two and five million variants
right and those variants mean there's
changes in letters along our genome we
know from some different public
databases what some of those variants
mean right if you have an A instead of a
T in this particular gene we might know
that that may increase your risk of a
particular condition or a particular
cancer or something like this or it
might mean that you are a carrier for
example of cystic fibrosis it doesn't
mean that you have the condition but you
could pass it on to your children right
so we know some of those things now the
key here is that we have if not the best
clinical team we have one of the best
clinical teams in the world right so we
have an incredibly experienced team that
most actually the largest segment of our
team if you like we have over
50 people doing interpretation from
computer sciences MDS
engineers doctors geneticists genetic
counselors so the interpretation of the
result is really the key here right
sequencing is quickly becoming a
commodity right you can sequence DNA in
different machines in different
countries right and you can get good
quality data the key here is who
interprets that information so that it
you know it's done at a high quality
okay and then to be able to then act on
some of the changes thank goodness we
are now exploring the genetic
engineering technologies that can take a
mutation like a cystic fibrosis and be
able to potentially change that so we
don't pass it down to our children so
there's different things look let's be
very clear we are still in step two out
of a hundred of understanding and
exploring everything in our genome we
are early on right but but but given
that there is already a lot of very
useful information and I'm happy to give
you an example if you like on my genome
yes please for example so I have a risk
associated with a condition called
pulmonary fibrosis it does not mean that
I'm gonna die tomorrow from it but
certain lifestyle aspects could trigger
as I grow older to create this fibroids
in my lungs so I stay away from
construction sites places where there
are small particles either from stone
metal wood that by inhaling them that
could eventually trigger that condition
in me
so I've adjust my lifestyle in a way
that is relatively easy and that will
probably have an effect on me not
getting these fibroids in my lungs or at
least delaying it yes right and that's
the type of thing where it's actionable
right now there are other things for
example I carry three conditions that
are not life-threatening and when my
wife and I decided to have a baby maybe
Julia who's now six months old we we
also noticed we also she also knows in
her genome that she
not carry those so therefore we don't
need to worry about that and it's just
good to know right though that is more
of a good to know we can read some
literature about it you can you know you
can prepare yourself now there are some
conditions where we know the risk of
getting something like Alzheimer's right
if you have a efore variant in your apoE
gene you know that your your chances of
getting Alzheimer's are much much much
higher than the general population after
a certain age and my dad died of
Alzheimer's so this is sort of very
personal to me so I wanted to know if I
have that variant one because I wanted
to prepare myself better now I do not
have that variant which doesn't mean
that I won't necessarily get the
condition I can get it for other reasons
that is not genetic right but unless
likely to get it but at least I've
informed myself more about the latest
literature the latest studies the latest
clinical trials etc so even when you
find out something I mean your genome
that has to do with a terrible condition
for which there is no treatment that
doesn't mean you can't do anything about
it you can inform yourself you can find
out who was doing the research who were
doing the clinical trials right when you
think about it for it for your kid if if
unfortunately you know all by genetic
chance one of my two daughters had a
condition that was genetically triggered
even if there was no cure I would go and
make sure that I know everybody doing
the quote you know the science at the
edge of that field because I would want
to be the first in line eventually to to
be there ready for a clinical trial or a
treatment or something like this and
then what would it look like then to
describe the difference between a whole
genome sequence at veritas versus what a
23andme does Nabila genomics what would
be the big difference yeah that's that's
a great question so there's two main
different technologies genotyping and
sequencing so what 23andme does and
ancestry DNA is genotyping which is they
look at a very small percentage of your
of your genome right so in the case of
of 23andme they will look at something
like less than half of one person
and of your whole genome right and the
technology allows you to ask questions
for what you already have the answers
for
so you're basically asking is there an a
here or the yes no okay I know already
what that means is there a T here yes I
know what that means she basically
asking questions for which you already
have the answers to you cannot go and
ask additional questions right it's a
one-time transaction and you have those
answers and that's it and that also
because of the this technology you have
very limited actual medical useful
information right so the example this
bracha one and braca two genes brca1
brca2 which are you know are well known
for increasing if you have a mutation
that is pathogenic and neither of those
two genes you have a higher chance of
getting breast cancer for example using
the 23andme test they only look at three
out of thousands of variants which mean
the result that you're gaining is very
limited because it's actually only
useful for less than 1% of the general
population if you want to look at your
risk for breast cancer in your bracha
brca1 or brca2 genes you need to
sequence completely the genes and you
only do that when you do whole genome
sequencing so that's the difference
genotyping small amount of DNA limited
information that comes out of that and
you're asking questions for which you
know the answers to
now sequencing you're literally sequence
almost all for technical reasons but
let's just let's just think your
sequence all your genome right 6.4
billion base pairs and for some of those
findings we have answers and some we
don't because we're still discovering
right but not only can we give you more
complete and actionable and medically
relevant insights but we can also go
back six months later and say Alan you
sequence your genome six months ago and
now there's some new research happening
that identified ten more genes
associated with a condition that you're
interested in let's say schizophrenia do
you want us to go and look and see we
know what what do we find in your genome
sure you don't need to spit again you
digitized it's basically a file and we
could just go search it and give you
back that insight so it basically is a
resource for your life that you can go
back and extract value from and that's
difference between sequencing and
genotyping and look I think part of this
evolution into the era of the social
genome is it makes no sense to do
anymore genotyping tests the only reason
this was done it was because it was
easier to do it and it was cheaper but
as the cost of sequencing your whole
genome drops down and drops down and
drops down to a couple of hundred
dollars there is no reason to do
genotyping because you're missing a huge
amount of information and this takes us
all the way to how this is being done
now a million times a million genomes
are already on the path to be sequenced
by 2021
yeah so look the talking about the
future is always is always difficult
right we we've we have an idea of how
fast we're scaling and I'll give you an
example last November we decided to to
offer a thousand genomes to the first
thousand customers that would come to a
website for 199 dollars and we thought
we will do that for 48 hours either 48
hours or a thousand genomes whatever
comes first
and we sold out in less than six hours
mm-hm and we spent three hundred and
fifty eight dollars on marketing mm-hmm
which is basically nothing yeah right so
the demand is there
you know this year we'll probably finish
between fifteen and seventeen thousand
genomes next year were somewhere between
eight and ten times that so you know
where we are collectively on a path to
to to have sequence a million people in
twenty twenty one twenty twenty two that
is the idea right and partly because as
soon as we have a really really good
standardized set of genomes sequenced we
can now deploy machine learning tools to
start to do research and identify new
relationships between
Jeanne's Fino typical data and
conditions which you can do with just a
few genomes right that is where
precision medicine really comes to to
exist or to realize ones we're able to
identify relationships between genetic
traits and you know genetic
characteristics we know typical
characteristics across a large set of
standardized genomes yes yes so the data
enables the insights that we would
really like with precision medicine yeah
and there is no precision medicine first
of all without you sequencing your
genome like because how are you know
event to in order to affect you right
you need to know what are your genetic
characteristics and other things in
order to provide a precision treatment a
precise treatment right and also in
order for us to identify all of these
new insights we need large-scale
standardized genomes and I say
standardized because for the most part
over the last twenty years the people
that have been doing you know sequencing
DNA including genomes you know it's a
scientist that has mm raked together in
his own spreadsheet then there's another
scientist that she applied for a grant
and put them in a different database
like they're all distributed in
different standards from Excel to your
own hodgepodge you know duct tape system
we need to standardize them and we also
have obviously a data strategy for that
yeah yeah that yeah to be able to
actually get these key insights I want
you to speak on some of these everyday
Assisting aspects that a whole genome
sequence can actually do for you so you
gave us some of the of the red yellow
and and what was the last color of the
green well we just calling great it's
just great like it's noteworthy its
right to know trying to knows because
this right this dives into everything
from the current nutrition choices that
we make to our health and life insurance
to diseases and enhancements that's
right dating matching there's so many
interesting things the marketplace for
research is so cool like you
with the amount of data we can actually
open up the machine learning algorithms
to find new relationships so you should
start exploring this area with us excite
people about the social jido yeah I mean
I'll give you an example of not only the
breadth but also the speed at which this
is happening so yesterday we had a we
were had a discussion with George Church
jasonkelly and Karl Schmieder and myself
around synthetic biology genetic
engineering opportunities and risks and
one of the things that George mentioned
is look there may be some people
interested in using genetic engineering
not just to address diseases etc but to
introduce additional diversity among
human population we understand the
importance of diversity from the
biological perspective evolutionary
perspective and also other aspects right
so just think about that for a second
not only are we going to be able to
start addressing over time certain
conditions first it'll be monogenic you
know conditions eventually some more
complicated but also the ability to
introduce genetic engineering to the
human population has also to do with
things like diversity right and that's
yesterday today you and I are talking
about this right after this I'm gonna go
to this event where we're talking at
hora Medical School with an other group
of people around preventive genomics how
do we scale having people sequencer
genome to prevent the onset of
conditions right and and we know that
this is already being introduced in the
clinical setting for example the Mayo
Clinic we have a collaboration with them
and in their executive health program
they offer our product so if you come
and do your checkup your annual checkup
to check everything they will also
sequence your genome if you want and
also use that information to prevent
certain things from coming along right
now in the afternoon we'll have a panel
today talking about the social genome
digital health and genetic engineering
to address very specific things and
today is announce in the paper as you
know online as you may have seen there's
a new genetic engineering therapeutic
company that is going to be starred
Verve therapeutics that was just
announced today address
cardiovascular right so that the number
of things that are happening around our
understanding of our genome together
with other bio data and how to actually
offer a product or a service to people
is starting to expand right and so where
does this go in the next 5 10 15 20
years health insurance programs that
take that into account we know already
that different insurance companies are
looking into the space to be able to
better understand your particular risks
right so health and life insurance you
bet somebody is already introducing we
already do it in certain communities for
example in some traditional Jewish
communities sort of a bit of niche
matchmaking depending on certain you
know certain genetic characteristics
right so a more broadly genetic
influenced tinder world short where do I
get a service if one of my kids has a
particular condition or or even if it's
I'm in the pregnancy process or embryo
who's gonna offer the different services
to be able to address and genetically
engineer out if you like a particular
condition it's it's coming I said five
years if that doesn't matter five ten
fifteen of course some of this is gonna
take some time but we're entering that
space right so everything from the hard
core science and reading and edit and
reading your genome to start to add it
and to offer different products and
services is this dynamic that we're
entering right and it's similar to again
to the digital revolution right there
was very little you could do in the late
80s with your little Radio Shack you
know computer or your Commodore 1/16
there were very few little things we
didn't have any of all of the things
that we did today across our life right
so that's sort of a good analog to see
where we're moving towards there's
obviously legal issues political issues
you know ethical more on all of those
and they're very important than which
you you know talk about them as well so
then what does it look like for someone
that has a concern about their data
privacy you know you listed that your GD
P are compliant so teach us about this
yeah so I mean privacy is obviously a
very important topic not just for us but
for many players in the industry and by
the way which is not different from
other industries right there were times
where people say I would never do online
banking because what if somebody hacks
my my account and I lose all my money
right I mean those were real concerns
and today certain number of banks get
hacked around the world every once in a
while and but we all do you know I mean
not only online banking and then one
PayPal and we I mean it's like you can't
imagine your life today without you know
digital transactions of your money
period right so it's not unique to to
health so what we do is of all the
possible standards that we can take we
take the highest standards both in terms
of our labs how we treat with the the
the data how it's encrypted how it's
stored all of that we apply the highest
standards right but this is more of an
important topic not just for veritas but
for any other player right
why because understandably many of our
consumers group together a concern that
is oh well Facebook is you know selling
this data and and 23andme did a deal
with a pharma company then all of this
is out of my control it's a very
understandable fear right so what we
need to do is we need to just continue
building a trusting you know a trust
relationship with our with our consumers
with the members of the Veritas family
that not only are we taking the highest
standards that the service that we're
providing to them is focused on what
they need and how they need right and
and evolving our services to respond to
very specific needs while still in the
back you know in the back end taking all
the technical precautions and encryption
etc etc etc right so you know will there
be some some hacking in this space at
some point of course like there is no
we've seen that every time we have a new
sort of technology that allows for some
people to abuse this of course we're
trying to do the
we can too to avoid that and not be you
know those affected but I think this is
you know this is we need to have these
conversations and there's also let me
point this out so I was having a
conversation with a friend and he said
look I'm concerned that my my genome is
stored even though you encrypted and you
know and I said look why are you
concerned it's like well because it's
it's a it's my health data and I want it
to be secure and I said okay are you
concerned that your last lab work and
your last x-rays that you did at your
hospital are still being sent around
from fat via fax like well no and
actually that's a good point right like
we've already assumed that when it goes
into the healthcare system
it's okay it's it's fine it's good
enough even though we know it's
completely hackable and even though we
know it happens every once in a while
okay so we need to take a stand you know
we need to take a much better stand that
what is the the method right now or the
if you like the level of of security in
the traditional healthcare system now
the other question is well I'm concerned
because my health insurance my one to
know that I'm not as healthy as I am and
therefore they're gonna you know
increase my premiums and I said okay
let's take that as an example let's say
that you have Blue Cross Minnesota and
they are Alan they are somebody there is
gonna try to look at your health and see
if you are less healthy than you said
you are and increase your premiums let's
just assume for a minute right the
easiest thing is to have a 21 year old
working there look at your Facebook page
and measure your waist size that will
give them a much clearer indication of
when are you likely to have something
like a cardiovascular issue than
anything else right now and if they want
to go a little bit further they could go
into your Instagram and look at what you
eat right now that's one case another
case is there is a bioinformatician
at this BlueCross BlueShield looking
through your genome identifying the
variants being able to just you know to
distill what are the risks and how much
likely are you that not which of those
two is more likely right that's one the
other is actually the
health insurance companies and life
insurance companies have all and many of
them have already approached us because
they're working to find ways to develop
new products that take into account your
genomic and other bio data to other to
be able to give you a product that
better positions you in a risk curve as
opposed to your mid-30s
you know white male of the zip code that
doesn't smoke which is very much like a
right so I think we're gonna see a
explosion of products and services some
of them will be more real than others
some of them will try to abuse it sure
but I think we're gonna see many more
products and services based on not just
our personal DNA but also other bio data
okay and then the the the current the
current state of of the of the
technology seems to be that we we take
what is the saliva samples and we
sequence that and then we store it and
then we gain access to it and then do we
get to be able to control any of the
data flows themselves out to researchers
do we get that permission yeah sure so
there's different ways to do this one
for example everyone that sequences
their genome with us we're at we asked
them if they would like to participate
in research more than 80% of people say
yes and of course we do that that
doesn't mean that we then give you a
genome to a researcher at all but if
there is a particular researcher working
on a let's say doing a cardiovascular
study and they want to ask a specific
question about 5,000 genomes
do they have this variant and also this
variant they could search we could give
them access to that search including
your genome but they don't get the data
they might just get the answer and say
oh yes actually among 5,000 people this
variant also exists when this other
variant is present right so that's the
type of research we're talking about
it's not like we hand over your genome
where anybody's genome to anyone so
that's that's an important point now
there are other platforms that are
emerging like Luna or
or nebula and others that are encryption
you know then are trying to figure out a
model where if you upload some of your
genetic information then can you control
bits you know bits of it to be able to
serve a particular research effort and
in some cases can you get remunerated
for that you know could you get somehow
paid and tokens or in some foreign some
currency for that and I think that's you
know we'll see more of those emerging I
think they're still trying to figure out
exactly what the model is but we're
excited that that that they're doing
that and look we we thought about this
for in the beginning the reason we
didn't start up a marketplace is because
you know as a start-up you got to focus
but but you know that doesn't mean we're
not gonna develop a marketplace like
that in the future
and then why would I not just be
comfortable with what is it the Personal
Genome Project and that enables me to
just upload all of my yeah sequence
right up on the internet for anyone to
be able to access yeah so the Personal
Genome Project is an effort that started
at Harvard Medical School over more than
10 years ago actually several of the
people that that founded that project
are part of the Veritas team so that
project the goal was to be completely
transparent and public with your
information and many people do that many
people upload everything not just a
genome but also other data into the
Personal Genome Project and and open it
up for research of anyone and many
people have we're talking thousands and
thousands so many people are very
comfortable about that and they don't
see really any risk you know or or the
risks that there are there they don't
they you know they don't they don't
worry about it so yeah that is
definitely another another avenue for
people to participate in research
mmm-hmm and the only risks that could
happen or something like that would be
that the health insurance provider could
look at that and they discriminate
against you or that potentially you
could maybe have some sort of a
malevolent attack against you that's
specific to your genome is this the
things to be considered that's what
people are concerned about so right
in the u.s. we have what is called the
Gina the you know which is basically a
non-discrimination piece of legislation
that does not allow a health insurance
company to discriminate against you
because of something that you have in
your Gina right now this does not apply
to life insurance companies so I had
recently a conversation with my life
insurance company and I said hey they
you know I I was sick ten years ago and
they work and they were concerned that
one of my organs would still be damaged
from that sickness ten years ago and I
said no I don't I I talked to my doctor
and I'm perfectly fine and they said
well we're still gonna have to pay you
ask you to pay a little more in your
premium and I said okay so you're
considering a risk possibility I said
okay how about I tell you that I also I
do not have an e for risk for
Alzheimer's I do not have a mutation in
my brca1 and brca2 for breast cancer
because if you're gonna consider things
risks to you know charge me more I want
you consider my risk profile to charge
me less oh no we can't do anything with
your DNA yet etc etcetera etcetera which
is right now they're basically hands-off
but they're actually are figuring out
and I know this you know from different
conversations that we have with them
trying to figure out not necessarily a
product that says oh let me look at your
genome but imagine for example that they
you know you know life insurance B says
Alan here's your policy here's your
premium by the way if you sequence your
genome and you meet with your doctor
reviewing those results we don't need to
see the information we actually don't
want any of that information but if you
demonstrate to us that you've sequenced
it and you talk with your doctor about
it we'll give you a discount why because
now you're more likely to know your
doctor is more likely to know one of the
risks or several of the risks that need
to be addressed which means that you
probably might be a healthier
individuals than otherwise so I think
we're gonna start to see some of these
which mean oh we saw it already in the
driving right if you put this little
thing that little gadget in your car and
you drive well we'll give you a little
discount now basically lowering your
risk
well yeah I think we're gonna see
something similar with with with whole
genome sequencing yeah there's so much
to still dive into really excited to get
to dive deeper into the nuance of the
science I'd love to hear some more of
the thinking around how to open notebook
science and open source the data and
then just decrease malevolent actors and
increase like the spiritual unity so
that we can have precision medicine be
at its fullest more easily there's still
so much to talk about and it's really
exciting to hear about Veritas bringing
the cost down to whole genome so you can
sink down to under a thousand dollars
you have the $200 that feels special and
and it's looking like hopefully in the
future we'll be able to get more and
more people sequenced even potentially a
million by 2020 ones very exciting yeah
we think the cost we think our price
whole genome sequencing is probably
going to be somewhere around five
hundred dollars by the end of this year
2019 and next year it'll be $200 or less
and therefore and that changes that
changes the whole space right that
changes our ability to have more people
sequenced we also participate in
research projects where we're now in a
collaboration with the genomes two
people project around the Frank of what
is called the franca Fund and I invite
everybody to research this where we're
also donating for X number of people
that sequence their genome we're
donating some genomes for
underrepresented minorities which is a
huge important aspect of research
happening we need more minorities to
participate and so we can you know
obviously understand some of the genetic
some of the genetic characteristics of
many of these minorities Hispanics
included as myself right yes yes yes
what a great model a kind of a
potentially even like Oh buy one donate
one model there's gonna be so
interesting yeah all right
huge thank you for tuning in everyone
Rico thank you so much for coming on to
the show we great my pleasure she ate it
yes welcome to the era of the social
genome that's right that's right it's
coming it's here we're really excited
everyone check out the links below to
Veritas also check out Rodrigo's links
below and going to have more
conversations with your friends your
family your co-workers on social media
about the era of the social genome start
talking about this more and what its
gonna be like go get sequenced ourselves
and support the artists entrepreneurs
and organizations around the world that
you believe in support simulation our
links are below so you can continue
doing cool things like coming to
Cambridge for interviews and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world huge thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace